Wow, was war das!
Zum ersten Bild eines Schwarzen Loches gibt
es noch eine Menge mehr zu erzählen und hier
gibt es Hammer-Animationen, die sich mit der
Entdeckung beschäftigen.
Bis gestern haben wir immer nur spekuliert,
wie ein Schwarzes Loch wohl aussehen würde
und gestern haben wir es zum ersten Mal gesehen.
Zwar noch extrem unscharf, aber die Vorhersagen
trafen zu.
Jetzt also mehr spektakuläre Bilder und Animationen.
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
spannende Sciencevideos abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Los geht’s.
Herzlich willkommen.
Wie konnte dieses Bild nur entstehen?
Das ist wirklich eine irre Sensation, denn
dafür wurde die Technik der Very large Baseline
Interferometry gemacht.
Auf deutsch Interferometrie mit sehr langen
Basislinien.
Mit diesen Linien sind die Abstände zwischen
verschiedenen Radioteleskopen gemeint.
Schon in den 50er Jahren wurde die technik
unter der Beteiligung von Roger Jennsion entwickelt.
Er entwickelte eine Technik, mit der die Aufnahmen
der teleskope über Atomuhren synchronisiert
werden.
Und dabei entstehen tatsächlich virtuelle
Teleskope, die fast so groß wie unsere Erde
sind.
Das liegt an verschiedenen Phänomenen.
Zum einen drehen sich alle Teleskope mit der
Erddrehung.
Das heißt dass sie jeweils aus einer anderen
Perspektive auf das Objekt sehen.
Dadurch decken sie einen erheblichen Teil
der Erdkugel ab und das Bild, das dabei entsteht
oder die immer größere Datenmenge ermöglicht
ein immer schärferes Bild.
Zum anderen blicken die Teleskope zu jeden
Zeitpunkt aus einem anderen Winkel auf das
Objekt.
Das heißt, dass durch die verschiedenen Perspektiven
auch eine riesige Anzahl an Störungen herausgerechnet
werden können.
Und zum anderen haben sie auch untereinander
verschiedenen Winkel.
Gäbe es diese Technik nicht wäre ein so
scharfes Bild von Mercier 87 bei weitem nicht.
Das Weltraumteleskop Hubble hatte uns bisher
die beeindruckendste Aufnahme des riesigen
Schwarzen Lochs geliefert.
Auf ihm war ein Jet aus dem Schwarzen Loch
zu sehen, der fast in unsere Richtung zeigt.
Jets entstehen aus dem Material der Akkretionsscheibe
und werden durch verschiedenen Effekte rund
um das Loch senkrecht zur Drehachse des Lochs
tausende Lichtjahre ins All geschossen.
Und die Akkretionsscheibe ist die Scheibe
die sich in diesem Fall mit 3,6 Millionen
Kilometern pro Stunde um das Schwarze Loch
dreht, in der sich Materie durch die hohe
Geschwindigkeit aufheizt, bevor sie im Loch
verschwindet.
Damit war klar, dass wir, wenn wir auf das
Schwarze Loch gucken von oben auf sehen, denn
die Akretionsscheibe dreht sich von uns aus
um das Schwarze Loch.
Es ist so als würden wir den Saturn von oben
sehen und die Ringe drumherum.
Denn hätten wir eine andere Perspektive würde
das Schwarze Loch diese Akkretionsscheibe
so warpen, dass es aus den verschiedenen Perspektiven
schon ziemlich seltsam aussehen würde.
Unglaublich, was das Schwarze Loch hier mit
der Akkretionsscheibe macht und hier wird
auch deutlich was wir sehen, nämlich nicht
das Schwarze Loch selbst, sondern seinen Schatten.
Der Ereignishorizint ist nämlich bei diesem
6,5 Milliarden sonnenmassen 100 Milliarden
Kilometer groß, zehnmal so groß wir unser
Sonensystem.
Den Schatten, den wir in der Mitte sehen ist
aber noch noch 40 Milliarden Kilometer groß,
also etwas viermal so groß wie unser Sonnensystem.
Wir sehen damit hier direkt die relativistischen
Auswirkungen eines Schwarzen Loches, dass
Zeit und Raum in atemberaubender Weise krümmt.
Materie, die sich dem Ereignishorizont nähert
wird aus unserer Sicht immer langsamer.
Solche Effekte kenn wir hier auf der Erde
zum Beispiel von Myonen, die fast mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit
auf die Erde zurasen.
Deshalb wirkt die Zeitdilatation auf sie.
Durch diesen relativistischen Effekt erreichen
sie trotz ihrer kurzen Überlebensdauer von
nur 2,2 Mikrosekunden die Erdoberfläche und
Pyramiden können durchleuchtet werden.
Aus unserer Sicht haben sie rund 10 Mal mehr
Zeit bis sie zerfallen.
Wow.
Das ist schon verrückt, und um das Schwarze
Loch ist alles nochmal deutlich verrückter,
was wir am Warp der Akkretionsscheibe sehen.
Und auch die Helligkeitsunterschiede in der
Akkretionsscheibe sind mit einem solchen Effekt
zu erklären.
Da wo sie sich in unsere Richtung dreht ist
sie heller, wo sich wegdreht dunkler.
Auf der Seite nämlich wo sich die Akkretionsscheibe
in unsere Richtung dreht schießt sie deutlich
Photonen in unserer Richtung, weil hier einfach
pro Zeiteinheit mehr Photonen zu uns geschossen
werden.
In der anderen Richtung, wenn sie sich von
uns wegdreht, werden weniger Photonen zu uns
geschossen.
Das ist schon alles ziemlich verrückt und
wir werden sich noch viel viel mehr zu dieser
Entdeckung in den Wochen und Monaten erfahren.
Sehr intensiv hat sich auch Doktor Whatson
mit dem Thema beschäftigt und beschreibt
nochmal sehr sehr gut, wie die Technik hinter
dem Bild aussieht.
Schaut also unbedingt bei ihm vorbei: Wie
fotografiert man ein Schwarzes Loch?
Draufklicken.
Anschauen und Doktor Whatson unbedingt abonnieren.
Es lohnt sich.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!